fallout from the democrats rocky showing
in this week's elections and how
president biden is now responding he
suggests it's just more proof that
democrats need to get things done in
washington it's all part of a new debate
within the democratic party after
republican glenn younkin won the
virginia governor's race and democrat
phil murphy only narrowly managed to
keep his job as the governor of new
jersey ed o'keefe is at the white house
where democrats may be reevaluating
their path to 2022 and 2024 ed good
morning good morning tony the
president's avoiding blame but that
upset in virginia and the close results
of new jersey put the president his
agenda and democratic control of
congress in jeopardy
what i do know is i do know that people
want us to get things done president
biden says democrats need to pass his
agenda
after republican glenn younkin's victory
over democrat terry mcauliffe in
virginia proved to be a warning sign for
democrats youngkin dominated across the
state winning the suburbs and rural
communities and doing well with women
younger voters and minorities groups
that had supported democrats
overwhelmingly last year
democratic governor phil murphy of new
jersey will keep his job but after a
narrow win it may come with a new path
forward forward by rejecting the
divisiveness and chaos that permeate too
much of our politics
in washington democrats are still
feuding over mr biden's social spending
and climate change plan the impasse is
holding up passage of a bipartisan
infrastructure bill party too
democrats i'm getting that bill passed
get it to my desk
house speaker nancy pelosi says the
president's social spending plan will
now include four weeks of paid family
leave but there's no guarantee it'll win
support from moderate democrats in the
senate let's do it and do it right and
on capitol hill democrats and
republicans may at least agree that
voters have their say this is an
earthquake i mean it really is an
earthquake this is a clear signal from
voters in a blue state i mean virginia
is a very blue state that they don't
like president bytes policies what i
heard was hey you guys got
the white house
the senate
the house
when you get more things done
so what's washington going to do about
it well house speaker nancy pelosi says
she will hold a vote this week on that
big social spending plan plus the
president's bipartisan infrastructure
bill but because that uh social spending
plan has paid family leaving it west
virginia senator joe manchin that key
moderate in the senate says
not so fast not a fan of that that
passes in the house it may not clear the
senate and the back and forth will
continue gail yeah the negotiations
continue and nobody i know likes an
earthquake thank you very much